hi everybody and thank you for being
here today my name is Maria what anyways
she said that before and I'm working as
a data scientist at LV and yes in case
you have never heard of LV is an
insurance company which has a
centralized data science team so we work
with all different of business areas to
improve the process of decision making
through the use of mataloni so as you
can imagine we deal with all kind of
different problems so sometimes we have
to either detect if cleanse is a fraud
or not or we have to price policies and
so on so the range of scenarios we have
to face is so broad and the consequences
of making our own decisions
our own decision in such a sea in such a
situation is so unpredictable and when
iming unpredictable I mean very
expensive for the company that not only
time not only time our main concern is
model performance sometimes our main
concern is how good are our predictions
and that's why I mean today here to
introduce the Khans
the concept of conformal predictor so
this is the outline of my presentation I
come from academia you can see that with
the outline and so first I will start
with a motivating example because always
makes easier to understand things then I
will formally introduce the idea of
conformal predictor and after that in
Section three and four I will explain
step by step how you can obtain a
conformal predictor for a classification
and for a regression problem then I will
show a couple of application a couple of
problem we have been working on Al bit
LV and we have been using this conformal
prediction with a very positive result
to end the presentation I will just
summarize the main ideas and conclusive
and before finishing I add some kind of
references for this topic because I
think is cool and maybe after the
presentation Samuel is very interesting
in wanna read a little bit more about
that so let's start this is the idea
imagine that our policy holder have an
accident with a car so after having the
accident he has to call Coulson
and report the accident then our task is
gonna be to decide whether the car was a
total loss or not so how do we do that
to do that we usually we have a set of
historical observation X is this
information available about the accident
like eight of the driver model of the
car and so on so on and why I is just an
eyeball yes or no for a total loss on
top of that we are gonna free to you we
are gonna be free to use any kind of
machine learning algorithm trick for the
data whatever we want to build our model
one our model is built we tested and
retested again and we are really
confident that the model performing is
amazing and then we are ready to go
Google life um this is what happened an
accident happens and then we run our
model and the model said that this is a
total loss so the claim handler is they
are looking at total loss and thinking
is this true so we've been let's give
him more information so we give him the
probability of being a total loss and we
tell him is 0.85 so almost what I lost
but we cannot really believe that
because how we compute this thing
sometimes even is not well calibrated
the probability that the classifier give
us so as we really believe in mature
learning then we thing okay if
everything that we did with past data is
gonna squeeze going to helping with the
prediction so if our model was like a
ninety percent Akira is in training test
and validation is gonna be ninety
percent accurate in the prediction so we
can even tell him is your answer is
ninety-one percent accurate okay it's
good and on top of that we can even
thinking and we will give you an 0.88
row can you see of the answer anyway
they claim handle will say okay fine but
he doesn't know what to do with this
measure so he wants something that make
him feel confident about the decision
and there is a way to do it is using
conformally interval you will be asking
why I pick informal intervals or
conformal prediction when is plenty of
their method that can give you some kind
of
prediction sorry confidence about your
predictions I don't know you can go for
resampling methods like bootstrapping
you can diaz assume that the target is
normal distributed and you just keep
going with the standard theory but what
happened with this method they all have
something in common you have either to
make an assumption about the algorithm
or about the data however if you use
conformal prediction you basically have
to assume nothing or very little just
this strange word I cannot pronounce in
English but I can say mean that the
order of your input doesn't matter okay
so it's nothing but you have to assume
on top of that there is another thing
that is good and you can use a conformal
predictor with any kind of machine
learning algorithm so it gives you a lot
of freedom it gives you an error bound
at the confident level that you set
before the starting that is also freedom
and kind of confident but this is what
we are looking for the probabilities are
well calibrated so when we say 0.85 is
really 0.85 so it helps a lot
it's very easy to implement at least
this basic idea this basic definition
that I'm gonna present here and assign a
mathematician I also like a lot idea
that this is really proving and you can
check this book where you will find all
the proof and you will see that I don't
like so now that I'm more or less
convinced you that is a good idea bit
source of conformal predictions I'm
gonna try to introduce the idea behind
the concept okay so now forget about
prediction materially any model and
everything yet focus on the intuition
let's assume that we have just a
probability distribution and we don't
make any assumption any assumption about
that and on top of this probability
distribution we have to define a
function that is going to measure
something about the sample of the
distribution but just to give you a clue
we are going to measure how we are is
the new sample because we this is what
we are looking for we are trying to find
something that we cannot trust so we
have the function we have the
probability
and then with raphae samples I know it's
not enough but it's a toy example so we
draw this sample we ask or this sample
using the function we have previously
defined if we assume that alpha 1 is
smaller than alpha 2 and so on and you
use a little bit of our imagination and
assume that they are equally distance ah
blah blah we can estimate the cumulative
distribution function of this thing of
this score and if we draw a new sample
for from the distribution and we assume
that the order doesn't matter because I
cannot say that then we can easily say
that the probability of this new sample
being a smaller than for example alpha 4
is gonna be 0.6 quite easy to see so
that's the idea behind the method do you
ask or your predictions you try to find
what is the queer one and then you can
see if the new one is top of the weird
thing or bottom of the awareness so
let's try now to connect this idea with
our real problem so if we try to connect
it the thing is like the probability
distribution is gonna be our historical
data set X is gonna be as useful
information we have about the problem
weii yes
the target we want to predict then we
define this function for example for
this example I have defined the function
of the absolute error of a regression
model here I have to say something
because if you see I have saved some
some some sorry son sample from the data
set to score the function at this point
I have to say that is true way to go
with this method either you read range
or model all the time or do you split
your dataset in that set for proper
validation and for proper training the
model and another set he has to
calibrate this scoring function as we
have to go like with the model I think
it's more efficient to go for with the
second one because we cannot allow I
mean it's really difficult to retrain
the model all the time plus is really
computationally very
fancy so I will all the time keep this
method but there the other is also
possible nothing is we save them 5 and
we left out 5 samples we asked all the
function in this 5 sample that we left
out and we get this time like 0.8 n 0.15
this time we are able to get the numbers
because we know that the true solution
and we also know that we have a
regression model that we have already
trained with our data and then again we
use a little bit of our imagination and
estimate the cumulative distribution
function and then we draw a new sample
and we score the sample and we have
absolute value of the true bread
prediction of the true answer of the
minister that is the prediction of our
model and this time we can really get
the probability because we know based on
the cumulative distribution function of
discourse that the probability of this
prediction is going to be for example a
small equal to 0.3 at a probability of
0.6 if we use the the properties of the
absolute value is gonna really easy get
that the true solution is gonna be in
between 1.6 1.7 and 2.3 with probability
0.6 so it's easy to get a confidence
interval and is not very complicated so
to formalize exactly this concept what
do we need it we wanna get the
confidence of if we want to compute a
conformal predictor for our problem so
as an input what do we need yes a set of
training example the only thing that is
simple
have to have to feed this assumption
that the order of the observation is
irrelevant that's it we are done with
assumption so is really free to go then
you have to define an unconformity
function that is the official name let's
say of the function f this function as I
said before is measuring how we are is
your example so if you use a little bit
your logic before defining it
should be something that give
lowest-cost to something that is similar
to your example and something very high
to something that is not even close to
what you wanna do common choice for this
function usually is some kind of
function of the underlying model but it
can be anything is just you have to be
creative and come up with a cool idea
and then probably it will work super and
you can use also the probability of your
of your classifier for the correct class
you can use the distant to the neighbors
you can I don't know use the number of
trees after your classification that say
that these days and the number of trees
that they're saying is no I mean just be
creative a little bit a more than create
if is try to understand what is going on
in your problem and then you will know
yes with intuition what kind of the
function you have to define then you set
a significant level this is a dangerous
part typing you pick a number between
zero and one and that's it then
the only thing you have to do is see how
these pins work so as I said we divide
the set of historical observation into
set one that we will use for training
and another one that we will use for
calibration we build our model using the
test the example that we have set for
training then we apply the function the
non-conformity function when we have
applied the not conformity function we
try to estimate the probability
distribution of this s course and then
the only thing we that is left is to
decide whether the new example will be
rejected or not to do that I mean it
sounds very complicated there may be
because I added a lot of formulas but
the idea is quite simple we only have to
compute this p-value and if you read the
formula they only need the only thing
you need to know is the amount of time
that in your probability distribution
your score is larger than the actual
score I mean it's like a percentage of
time that this thing is gonna happen and
then you have to decide whether this
will be in your final interval or not
and
is really easy to decide if it is much
larger than epsilon it is it is not
larger than a Scylla
it's not gonna be what do you get after
doing this you get something called
predictive freedom and that you can
prove that it will contain the truth
with probability 1 minus Epsilon
if you are solving a classification
problem you will get a set of labels
this set of label can be empty if it is
empty then you will always make the
wrong answer so don't trust your
classifier then if it is has only class
should be always true always if the
answer that you have inside is true of
course and if you have more than one you
will always be right on the other hand
if you are solving a regression problem
as a result you will have an interval a
real Imperva that is gonna contain the
true answer with probability 1 minus
Epsilon so this is the general idea and
now I'm gonna add yes like a little
recipe for classification or regression
a step by step as in case you wanna
implement it or use it and the thing is
like do I start with yours this is gonna
be fast you start with your set of
historical data you assume that the
order doesn't matter as useful do split
the data into said calibration and
training said you use the training for
to be in the classifier you define the
nonconformity function you have to come
up with a good idea to mention how we
are your samples then you apply this
function to all the all the points that
you have in the calibration set and you
set a significant level this is
basically the same thing for regulation
from classification and this is what is
changed so here is classification then
what you have to do is for a new sample
you take all the levels in your label in
your set of label and you compute the
score for every label when you have the
score for every level
the only thing you have to do is compute
the p-value for every level for a media
score of every level that is just
counting the number of time that in your
calibration set there is a sample with
an escort larger than your escort and
once you have done this for every level
you just decide whether this level will
be in your region or not just checking
if the p-value is larger than the
epsilon you said or not so easy not very
complicated for regression you have to
do exactly the same thing until I
stepped life is exactly same thing but
the only difference is that instead of
theta calibrate classifier you have to
fit a regression model the different
Ishqiya so one you set the epsilon and
everything is ready to go the only thing
you have to do is do order all the
alphas and now you don't have access to
all the possible solutions because the
target is a continuous target so what
you do is to compute the index of the
possible a score that will be associated
to your to your example so the idea is
quite simple you will get the 1 minus
epsilon percentile of the nonconformity
score you just get the percentile that
you are a set of the probability
distribution of the score they want that
you build before finally when you get
this alpha s plus minutes the prediction
is exactly what is your conformal
predictor now I think that everybody is
ready to compute this thing and a couple
of example that they are-- an
application that of a few problem that
we have had at lv so the first one is a
classification problem and it's exactly
the same problem that we were talking at
the beginning we have to find out
whether a god is a total loss or not the
data said the data set was real
imbalance what was a problem we use X
abuse as a classifier and the model had
that very good performance accuracy zero
in 91 the 0.87 validation 88 and raqqa
you see 88 not really a big difference
between train test and validation we can
say that there is no basically
overfitting we were white okay a new
accident happened so again the same
question are we confident or not I have
to say also then this problem we have a
restriction is that we had to minimize
the number of false positive because
full positive is unpredictable for the
company so it's expensive as I said that
there weaken so this is what we try then
we try to minimize this number of false
positives in positive using conformal
predictions the only trick thing was how
to define the nonconformity function and
this is what I did I define the
nonconformity function for this problem
as the average between the probability
for every class for every class of my
classifier plus a recalibrated
probability of the same class how I
recollected the probability I did it by
penalizing being total loss and I didn't
do any any fancy thing scikit-learn did
everything for me and you have the code
is really easy to reproduce so this was
the with this I believe is course and
then I had to compute for a new case
what was my predict predict pray big
thank you okay you have to make it
simple I will show the real result later
on but you have to make it simple let's
assume that in our calibration set we
only had nine examples okay so as I said
before we have to compute the p-value
per value per level and per new accident
and we have first all the values per all
the scores per level in our case we have
two levels one is total loss the other
one is non total loss and this 0.87 0.99
this is the average of the probabilities
of the one that is not calibrated plus
the one that is client calibrated
divided by 2 then I did a suckling the
same thing aya scored the prediction of
my model that is total loss support
the total loss I got 0.8 year 85 and for
non total loss I got 0.15 then I go to
my distribution of scoring and I just
can't just the percentage I have 0.85
five years counties one two three plus
eight are smaller than 0.85 so my
p-value is 8 divided by M plus 1 0.8 I
check if it is larger than the epsilon I
said that is 0.05 yes it is so it will
be in my predictor in my I'm sorry we
eat whatever in the Ray set of
predictions and the same for non total
loss I compute the score I go to my set
of labels I check how many of them are
smaller than larger than than the one I
have and then I just divide by the total
number by 1 I get a probability I check
if that probability is larger or smaller
than the confidence level that I said at
the beginning and if it is larger I put
it in my set so I get at the end I said
that contains the true solution we see
the point 95 probability what I okay
before saying how we use this thing I
this is notice actually the real this is
how you can implement this method is not
exactly the real implementation but I'll
be tossing allows us to release
everything that we do there so I just
fake something but can give you an idea
of how to do it the only thing you have
to do is define P values for every you
can even but do it optimize the same but
just to give you an idea you have to
define a p value for every of the labels
that you have and you just count the
number of time that your score is gonna
be a smaller than the score that than
the other score you sum up and you
divide by the number of element that you
have in the cell the same for all of
them and then you check whether it is
larger or not on the epsilon and then
you put it in the set in our case that
we use this conformally interval to get
rid of false positive was
really huh me these are more or less the
real number but not the real number
because envy nothing allows us to say
but anyway we have a validation set that
the lessons was half a million roughly
and 50,000 total losses in this in this
first row you can see that without any
conformal interval the number of false
positive was almost 10,000 then we use
this conformal interval we set an
epsilon 0.05 we recalibrate the
probability as I said the average of
post probabilities and then we can see
that we get with two classes seventy 67%
of the false positive so every time we
got two classes we were not sure that it
was a total loss and we stopped
classifying those as a total loss as a
result of all of these we decrease the
error of false positive in a 67% so
what's a lot of saving we save a lot of
money because some predictable is as I
said very expensive
I also another application that this
class if I say aggression problem this
doesn't look so great but anyway I will
try to tell him to show you how to
compute this thing and this is a real
problem somehow we have to find out the
price of the car the problem was that
the data set was not correctly labeled
so that was quite noisy we use a light
DBM to predict this thing the model
performin was quite okay we get a zero
point ninety five of in the air it was
call the roll the error is quite far
from the mean so we were really happy
and we thought that the model were
predicting quite okay so with is the
typical second that you do in insurance
you bin your out your target pair target
you count the number of example you have
in this bin and you compute the mean of
the average and on top of that you
compute the mean of your prediction you
can see that
when you we have followed up a survey
team we have this high yellow bar the
model is behaving quite okay and when we
don't almost have no servation the model
is doing something we but in general we
can see that the model have a quite good
performance but what happen if you
really plot what is happening point by
point it's really difficult to see I
mean it's not that the true value is so
order is that I order the true value and
on top of that I plot the real
prediction if I do it the other way
around
looks very noisy the true value but the
thing is like it's really difficult to
see anything there but here I blow up
yes 15 point and you can see how noisy
the predictions here is even when we
have such a good behavior in a model for
example here you can see like sometime
maybe it's like 50 pounds more or less
that is okay if you are not so accurate
with the price but in the middle you see
that the price is like one thousand two
hundred and we are saying that is
basically four thousand so we are really
far from the solution and this is not
about there was example like we show you
I could even show you something was so
what we did we try to compute the
conformal interval how to compute
conformal interval if you have a
regression problem so we did say we feed
the city we separate the test in label
and blah blah so we define a
nonconformity function our was more
fancy that this one but this one is just
for this example so I'm gonna have I
took the simple one and I define the
nonconformity function of the absolute
error between the prediction and the
truth we assume again that we only have
nine example in our calibration test the
calibration said we ordered all of them
in descending order as you can see these
are all the score for the point for the
points that I have in the calibration
set and now as I said before we have to
compute the zero point x things like the
second percentile of deadest
and this is what we do I miss yes you
get the illness to compute the
percentile and you compute the
percentile I mean there is nothing fancy
about computing horizontal everybody
know how to that how to do that so then
you take this alpha and this solve this
depredation of your model plus this
person time that you said with the
epsilon at the beginning is gonna be
your prey your conformal interval you
can see here that don't look at the
other one because it's super noisy the
data setting is really difficult to see
anything but in this a small one you can
see that the blue one is the true value
and you can see how this interval
contains the true value basically at 95%
of the time so the method is working
quite okay that's it that brings me to
the end of my presentation I'm gonna be
brief I just want you to keep in mind a
few ideas the first one is like good
model performance does not always mean
trustable prediction I think I have
convinced you with the plot of course it
depends on your goal if you wanna win a
Kargil competition probably an amazing
raka you see is enough but if you are
gonna make a decision using the
prediction of your model I think you
should be sure or you should trust trust
and how what you are predicting so
conformal predict another good thing
about another thing I want you to
remember is that a conformal parameter
is a useful tool and is not only about
getting conformer interval is also it
can be also used for differing
application it helped me a lot to reduce
the number of false positive it doesn't
assume a lot of faith a lot of things so
is cool because we can use it all the
time it's easy to understand I mean see
20 minute hang everybody now understand
what it is is really easy to implement
as well it's not very computationally
expensive
at least it's not very computationally
expensive this basic definition that I
presented today it can be more
computationally expensive if you use
another technique
I can guarantee a confidence level of
0.99 so it's telling you that you will
make an error of only 1% say you can
trust what you are predicting and on the
other hand on the negative can do you
have to is a little bit problem
dependent because you have to define
your own nonconformity function and is
not always easy you really have to
understand what is going on with the
error Roger of your model to be able to
define something that is going to be
really helpful and that's it before
finishing I just want to say that there
is a lot going on out there about
conformal prediction is plenty of paper
books and readings and someone is
interesting in the topic after this in
this presentation I will say yes go and
check because it's quite a nice
[Applause]
asking me that if I don't have all the
theater how handle how I handle the
uncertainty in that case dang i couldnt
use conformal prediction because i'm
assuming that i have enough information
to believe the error of to believe that
the error of my model is giving me extra
information yes you can use basic method
i said that at the beginning the only
good thing about that i can see about
the thing is like you don't have to make
any assumption i've been a mathematician
all my life I don't really like a
starting with okay it's normal but you
can see that it's not normal or I assume
that this is going to happen and it's
really true that it's not going to
happen so that's why I give it a try to
this method but this may be a personal a
personal choice
in the sense that at the least you can
believe what you are getting I like it a
lot
maybe you can get more accurate result
with another method but is always tricky
if you don't really fit all the
assumptions so that's what I think
recalibrated recalibrated probability
yes so I was curious about why you were
averaging and not used to that'd be a
calibrated probably because my whole
that was quite okay
and my goal in that time was so
the number of full positive men came up
with the idea of penalized a false
positive but recalculating would be some
fun way yeah why you are not using just
the calibrated probability and you are
averaging with you with the information
that my classifier was giving me because
the behavior was quite okay
I just wanted to penalize the
probability of the classifier so Michael
I was talking with a classifier I just
wanted to penalize it in some cases
especially in their false positive
that's why it's not really personal
choice is making if you just take the
calibrated probability you will have the
same problem maybe your accuracy or your
more than performin can decrease but the
moment you average both you just I I
realized that I was just realizing these
false positives and I was keeping their
geodesy under saying that what I was
penalizing that was possibly my our use
it but of course my goal here was clear
was reduce the number of false positive
maybe not very content that you need to
do something and this I don't know very
interesting presentation similar
questions why is our job just asked so
in your oppression problem it uses no
conformity basically absolute distance
between the prediction and the ground
truth I would have expected in the
classification problem that you wouldn't
use something like the cross entropy or
some other loss function with respect to
the ground to the classification what
the ground really classification is not
at all in the knock of our body function
at all does that work so the ground
through the new classification on
confirm a function does not appear so to
speak you just have the predictions and
you average them so certainly classes
again in the regression problem you are
doing the absolute distance between the
truth and the addiction right so in a
certain sense you're saying I scored the
errors and I only trust the ones when I
know that the error is not do you create
on this point but in the classification
while the ground truth is not in the
nonconformity function so I don't
understand other makes you confident
[Music]
function for the regression problem and
you think it's very simple that's your
question question is why is not the
obvious one
why is not the loss function of the
classification problem have you tried it
didn't work for me something is free I
mean you if you a very good idea what if
I were to say I might try do you see you
have to use I'm sure I just wanted to
understand the reasoning I just wanted
to show what is important you can easily
compute it and we and I just picked this
example when it wasn't the best
you